there's a running Rotten Tomatoes pool
in the office right now it was betting
where it's going to fall
really where are you bidding I have 57
57 which which basically means that fans
with Mighty Morphin are going to have a
lot of fun with it and that's all I want
from that that's all I want too yeah you
know when you say Power Rangers people
are going to give it a hard time no
matter what course which is unfortunate
segue into introductions I'm Greg Alva
how are you with me perry Nemiroff oh
and Emma rough now the rule camera the
accent alright okay remember rule house
targaryen oh I don't know about you now
you'd be a Lannister for sure no Gary
here you know from Collider videos and P
Nemiroff on Twitter and Instagram all
over there Perry is a fan of Power
Rangers that's why she's giving it a
terribly decent score on Rotten Tomatoes
I want this wicked man but she is saying
the critics score will not reflect her
own opinion necessarily there's a chance
the audience will not get a lot higher a
little nervous I'm nervous I want
everybody to love it I want everybody to
understand why I'm with my source like
every time I talk about it early he's
going to Soph no matter what and you
know it's goofy and fun I think it's
wise if I have a fun time and I'm
entertained that's all that matters in
my life Cooke called real cool but it
happens out of Gigi I love it
real it won't be beautiful meanings of
years without a lock is going on hey
guys I'm in high school already looks
different from the source material very
very true feel like they're gonna walk
in there and find the xenomorph Power
Rangers peers that's fine by me
azalea this is real like over the
infestation babies all just Just Breathe
okay
something funny happening alfalfa's good
up yours alfalfa Wow pretty crazy
designs
ah
[Music]
top right it has to be well you okay you
got some powers that that was that was
solid or watch you're real you're real
you're real
that's why it's called yeah that's why
it's called real so this got sent over
from Rick Gainey regaining to send me a
several videos on our Facebook which I
don't check as often as I should in the
messages just tired receiving all these
dick ticks you know yeah I'm is that why
you don't check your Twitter messages -
yeah I'm keeping you gonna mean dick
pics I'm getting a better sense of I
mean that's a very specific scene I
don't think I'm yeah and I would like
really to be a defining no not at all
because it's misleading it's making it
seem like there were just something
scarier than alpha 5 yeah yeah it shows
their chemistry which don't know is
something that I really wanted to see
and yeah you know I don't know if that
was the most innovative and even like
real feeling dial on him if we did seem
like I'm supposed to be a Power Ranger
but at the same time it seemed like that
it must suck to be an actor can you
imagine I'm walking around the set for
god knows how long is being like react
like this I was still so stupid doing
that but they sold it well I think it
works they did sell but they did sell
well because I'm kind of hoping that the
acting was a little cheesy yeah because
I feel like when people I know like
that's the Power Rangers I grew up
unlike the og Power Rangers show yeah
I've said before that like I'm okay with
it being cheesy because that show was
singular cheesy how do you mean real pop
no not laic was on Netflix you should
watch mighty morphin time my boobs yeah
our marathon every once in a while
that's what I'm doing and I'll just put
them so Terry was it fun even when I was
a kid though
while was airing I was like this is
really cheesy you know I was a kid I was
aware it wasn't like a movie you
back on and go or show you look back on
it let me feel bad because I guess I
might have been aware but I didn't care
and I took it's so important I just
remember when it went arrows sitting on
the bus to school and having full
wardrobe over here he's cool about what
the characters were up to see that I
felt that way about the first Power
Rangers movie without house I thought
man I wish that would be a question for
me on this road am mean empowering idea
of the villain first how are you oh that
movie I thought like that was actually
really serious cool movie I watched it
later on the college was pretty corny
actually yeah I do want a serious Power
Rangers movie or TV show it's like the
adi shankara's yeah yeah Shane Carwin
highlighter it that quite a bit
that was really cool I'm okay with like
the cheesy acting that was a really dark
scene when I see the trailers of testing
my only concern is that it will become
like a Josh Trank movie where it just
goes into like okay you're taking
yourself too seriously and that's all
but one thing I don't want permit it to
take itself too seriously I don't think
they would do that I mean the trailers
haven't really done that too much they
sure you know the first trailer
definitely made it feel more of like a
serious coming-of-age nor whatever ever
since like the more and more promos that
drop it does feel like they're having
fun and like that last one that showed
finally the Zords and Adam was a big
gold or you can't not can't take that
seriously Judean Israelite is a good
director I feel like he didn't really
get a fair shot of project Almanac
actually in a similar situation with
this just because people were like oh
it's teen found-footage it's gonna suck
and then everyone just said it's tough
you know it was a little rough around
the edges in some respects but I think
that was one heck of a first feature so
I had my fingers crossed for him Wow
Perry I've had several people with me
when I like over the course of many
Power Rangers trailers and did I
convince you I feel like you've really
opened my mind to being more optimistic
about this movie success because I've
been like right in the middle of I'm
hopeful but I'm doubt this is let
anymore - how long give you a little
more open to it now there's a little
part of me I think it's just because I
care so much yeah you know I can't help
but to be a little worried we want to do
yeah like a true fan is writing the
optimistic wave right now has good yeah
and you seem like you have well jug like
if this was a movie fights I feel like I
have a pen argued argument know why to
look forward about our agent I hope it
would be the same after why to see it
yeah we have to wait and see at this
point I'm not my screening invite how
badly you're right about those II don't
work that out of like yeah I got alia
know your emails obvious reasons alpha
five yeah this little arm think you can
do that not an Amish oh no no this is
two ways to react to this one that's
cool too you're ruining my childhood by
adding them which one should I go with
definitely the latter don't look at
everything no and I've been saying this
a lot of everything go with that school
you go with the school what it what
order did you say it I said that's cool
long day oh it's a guy don't want you to
come across like you don't understand Oh
God well you know I'll tell you doing
things on it like you don't want I think
I found one video recently I said
irregardless irregardless really upset
me and I caught it after I said like
there's no backtracking in a race
nothing well I'm glad you got my back
yeah whatever the one odds if guys good
yeah a positive one was that's the one
I'm going with if you look at the Power
Ranger suits and you look at the Zords
you have to update output to that degree
also true although which I feel like
alpha is the one of the few characters
they could have kept practical effects
no it's a fair point they caught up the
way that alpha looks now I don't find
too jarring because it matches
everything else but at the same time I
don't think practical would have been
all that crazy of an idea either
especially if it was just one character
you would think they could have gone
that route okay
well Perry you convinced me I mean I was
already going to buy it the ticket to
this regardless you're a heartless
you're regardless not a word not a word
so I'm sure you guys are especially when
it
I know how to close out videos very
smooth I can tell I can tell you're
you're you're over 2 at this point and
Ricky Ricky Gervais thanks for asking
again subscribe is the real rejects
Perry narrow mom Amara Robbie never up
13 emerald gon the stoic house is on
Collider videos as well and she has a
Twitter and Instagram P numerals yeah
this is spelling right here for you guys
so you don't don't get dumb and go with
the latter thought you had or former I
don't know die should I mean the other
key regardless so figuring out yeah